bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir une enquête glaçante sur la
fabrique des filles dites facile et
cette enquête c'est la votre l ASI
bonsoir merci d'être là la réputation et
votre premier livre aux éditions les
échappées vous êtes reporter à Charlie
Hebdo et vous êtes retourné à crille
dans looise là où SH 15 ans a été brûlée
vive par son ex-ptit ami en 2019 vous
avez rencontré ses amis les autres
filles du quartier elles n'ont pas
entendu parler du Mitou vous nous direz
pourquoi et elles vivent sous une forme
de contrôle social important sur place
on en parlera toutes les deux dans la
seconde partie de cette émission notre
grand débat ce soir sur la pénurie de
médicaments antibiotiques corticoïdes
anticancéreux les ruptures de stock sont
très préoccupantes et l'hiver qui arrive
n'arrange rien alors qui est responsable
l'État les labos les pharmaciens tous
les acteurs de la filière sont convoqués
par le ministre de la Santé la semaine
prochaine on en débat dans un instant
sur ce plateau enfin ns affranchi ce
soir le billet d'humeur de l'avocat
Bertrand Perrier le mot de la semaine de
notre sémiologue Mariette d'grand et
action planète la chronique écolo du
vendredi avec Léa Falco voilà pour le
menu on y va alors d'si ça vous regarde
c'est tout de
suite
[Musique]
le phénomène est mondial et il n'épargne
pas la France alerte rouge sur la
pénurie de médicaments dans notre pays
plus de 3700 ruptures ou risqu de
rupture de stock ont été signalé en 2022
par les autorités sanitaires et toutes
les catégories de médicaments sont
concerné alors comment est-on arrivé là
et surtout que peut-on faire dans
l'urgence bonsoir Benedict bertolom
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
directrice générale de l'Union des
syndicats des pharmaciens d'officine
bonsoir Frédéric bizard ravi de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau professeur
d'économie à l'ESCP et président de
l'Institut de santé bonsoir Nathalie
coutinet ravi également de vous
retrouver économiste de la santé à
l'université Sorbonne Paris-Nord et puis
un député représentant la majorité va
nous rejoindre à distance depuis sa
circonscription de de laavyon dans dans
un instant lors ASI c'est un sujet qui
nous concerne tous euh peut-être que
vous avez dans dans vos proches des des
patients qui qui souffrent de de cette
pénurie n'hésitez pas à interroger nos
nos invités si vous le souhaitez on va
commencer par planter le décor de quoi
manque-t-on le plus et à qui la faute
c'est dans le chrono de Blacko qu'on
accueille tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir
Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
cette pénurie de médicaments alors on a
beau être uneémission d'actualité faut
bien reconnaître que la pénurine
médicament c'est pas nouveau hein
simplement ces dernières années quand ça
s'est produit on a tendance à attribuer
ça à des circonstances exceptionnelles
bien sûr le covid en 2020 où on a
découvert que l'un et la Chine fabriqua
80 % des produits actifs et qu'on avait
un petit problème de souveraineté mais
aussi par exemple bah l'hivier dernier
on s dit c'est la triple épidémie donc
bronchiolite grippe et covid qui fait
que certains médicaments étaient
extrêmement demandés et que ils étaient
peut-être en rupture de stock à cause de
ça sauf qu'au-delà de ces circonstances
qui ont pesé c'est vrai il y a un vrai
problème de fond c'est que la
consommation mondiale de médicaments
augmenté de quasiment 40 % ces 10
dernières années parce que des pays en
développement comme la Chine l'Inde on
consomme de plus en plus et donc ça pèse
sur un marché qui est mondial résultat
bien ça a des conséquences sur ce qui se
passe en France euh regardez il y a en
2014 il y avait 91 médicaments qui
étaient en risque de rupture de stock
l'an dernier il y en avait bah quasiment
20 fois plus donc on voit que
effectivement ce n'est pas un problème
tout à fait récent mais face à cette
situation à cette situation on a déjà
entendu des annonces notamment le
président de la République si vous vous
souvenez c'était au moin de juin dernier
il avait dit bien dans ce cas il va
falloir relocaliser 50 médicaments
vraiment essentiels dans notre pays dans
les prochaines années mais comme les
usines ça ne se construit pas d'un
claquement de doigt bien il faut
continuer de faire face au aux pénuriies
qui sont toujours là donc le
gouvernement a dressé une liste de 450
médicaments essentiels don le principe
c'est que les industriels doivent
forcément avoir 4 mois de stock de ces
médicaments donc là on est à l'abri de
la pénnerie normalement oui mais voilà
le stock existe mais apparemment il est
pas super bien géré c'est pas moi qui
dit ça c'est le ministre de la Santé
Aurélien Rousseau qu'on écoute on a 450
médicaments qui sont mis sous
surveillance par l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament et en effet
globalement on a du stock au niveau
national et après certains de nos
concitoyens ne trouvent pas il y a
certaines très grosses pharmacies qui
commandent direct aux industriels et qui
font du du surstock et donc des petites
pharmacies qui elles n'arrivent pas à
avoir
il y a donc un problème donc le ministre
va essayer de le résoudre la semaine
prochaine en réunissant l'ensemble des
membres de la filière pharmaceutique en
attendant les résultats de cette
concertation le gouvernement a déjà pris
des mesures donc vous avez peut-être
entendu parler par exemple pour les
médicaments qui risquent d'être en
pénurie bah voilà on va les vendre à
l'unité comme ça se fait par exemple les
pay hosaxon pour pas stocker chez soi
des médicaments qu'on a pas utilisé puis
il y a des questions de prix aussi
l'amoxyline qui est l'antibiotiqueine
ouais j'en j'ai oublié une syab
l'amoxyyine qui donc est le
l'antibiotique le plus vendu en France
va connaître une augmentation de 10 % ça
fait 20 centimes par boîte c'est pour
inciter les industriels à en fabriquer
plus et là on aborde un autre problème
du sujet c'est qu'en ce moment les
industriels du médicament préfèrent
plutôt fabriquer des médicaments très
innovants qui demandent de gros frais de
recherche parce qu'ils vont pouvoir les
vendre très cher et du coup ils mettent
plutôt de côté les médicaments dont le
brevet est connu de tout le monde mais
qui est tombé dans le domaine public sur
lequel on fait finalement très peu de
marge alors évidemment je peux vous
donner un exemple vous allez voir le
médicament le plus vendu en France c'est
le doliprane donc on se dit formidable
c'est une chance de fabriquer ce
médicament bah pas du tout çaofi préfère
confier ça à une branche une autre
branche de l'entreprise une autre
entreprise pour ne pas plomber ses
marges alors je je ne pense pas pouvoir
vous tirer des larmes en évoquant les
problèmes de Big Pharma de toutes ces
industriells du médicament et pourtant
regardez le patron de biogarant qui est
une marque française de médicen
générique bon marché son diagnosticque
alors que l'équation économique n'est
plus au rendez-vous pour 144 de produits
a 144 médicaments biogarants qui ne sont
plus rentables aujourd'hui nous avons
décidé de les conserver jusqu'à
maintenant de maintenir le dialogue avec
les pouvoirs publics de continuer à les
fabriquer en France et en Europe pour
les mettre à disposition des patients
bref voilà j'espère que vous avez un peu
près saisi la situation cela dit ça fait
3 ans je fais des chroniques sur des
problèmes assez compliqués j'en ai
rarement vu aussi complexes que la
pénuerie du médican mais c'est bien de
le reconnaître merci beaucoup Stéphane
on va revenir sur les causes profondes
de de CP pénuie on a compris qu'elle ne
date pas d'aujourd'hui mais déjà
Benedict bolome qu'est-ce que vous
répondez au ministre de la Santé
Aurélien Rousseau qui dit clairement les
les pharmacies bon les plus grosses
pharmacies font des surstock il y a pas
de pénurie au niveau national c'est ce
qu'il dit mais pour anticiper les
éventuels problèmes de de rupture à
venir peut-être le mois ou dans 2 mois
et bien et bien les les pharmaciens
préfèrent garder les médicaments dans
leur dans leurs entrepôts si j'ose dire
oui alors les médicaments ils sont fait
pour être dispensés au aux patients donc
si on a des médicaments on les dispense
immédiatement au patients donc je pense
que c'est voir les choses par le petit
bout de la lorniette et que nous on est
dans un système qui dysfonctionne donc
aujourd'hui en fait les pharmaciens ils
ont besoin de répondre à la demande des
patient par exemple un patient qui va
sortir de l'hôpital et qui a besoin
pendant que le pharmacien est de garde
la nuit de répondre à cette demande et
ben dans un système qui dfonctionne il
va stocker des médicaments après ça veut
pas dire que c'est la cause principale
je pense pas que ça soit la cause
principale des ruptures c'est une
accusation quoi un peu injuste
malhonnête qu'il vous qu'il vous fait là
peut-être mais en tout cas je pense pas
que ça soit la cause principale encore
une fois des ruptures il y a d'autres
facteurs beaucoup plus concrets
notamment au niveau des industriels qui
doivent être aussi identifiés je pense
par exemple au stock de médicaments
aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu' il y a
des stocks de médicaments chez les
laboratoires et pour autant il y en a
pas chez les pharmacies d'officine je
précise dans TR jeu qu'on a essayé
d'inviter sur ce plateau les industriels
de la de la pharmacie qu'on a pas qu' n'
pas réussi de quel médicament
concrètement les les pharmaciens
manquent le plus parce qu'on a
l'impression que ça concerne tout du
plus essentiel au plus le vous sortez
d'une opération par exemple pour éviter
des effets secondaires il peut manquer
un médicament avec des conséquences
graves si si vous ne ne l'avez pas avec
même des des risques quoi de décès on en
est là aujourd'hui bien sûr bienû on en
est là on en est là et aujourd'hui le
rapport du Sena l'indique très
clairement il y a 37 % des patients qui
sont confrontés à une pénurie
d'approvisionnement en 2023 je pense que
c'est assez euh assez dramatique et puis
ça concerne en effet comme vous le dites
tous les médicaments que ce soit les
médicaments
psychotiques les antibiotiques on en
parle énormément mais c'est pas
uniquement les antibiotiques c'est aussi
les anticancéreux et et ce qui est
dommageable aujourd'hui c'est que
finalement on a l'impression que il faut
s'habituer à vivre avec les ruptures que
c'est normal en fait bon ben il y a des
ruptures donc mais en fait c'est pas une
situation normale il faut trouver des
solutions pour anticiper et prévenir
alors j'anticipe peut-être mais en tout
cas sol solution qu'il faut trouver
c'est pas et c'est ça ça doit rester des
situations exceptionnelles Frédéric
bizarre les causes profondes alors il y
a il y a du conjoncturel et il y a du
structurel il y a la il y a la guerre en
Ukraine il y a aussi toute une série de
de de de matériels donc qui manque avec
avec cette cette guerre il y a il y a le
structurel c'est la c'est la
délocalisation massive on est totalement
dépendant aujourd'hui des des principes
actifs qui sont fabriqué massivement en
Chine et en Inde oui je crois que vous
avez raison il faut regarder les les
causes il y a juste trois choses pour
quand même comprendre que le le
politique ne veut pas regarder ces
causes là et et préfère essayer de
trouver des solutions de surface mais
mais qu'il y a des causes profondes
ettant qu'on qu'on s'y attaquera pas je
pense qu'on règlera pas le problème la
première cause c'était très bien dit par
votre collègue c'est qu'il y a un
déséquilibre structurel entre l'offre et
la demande sur un certain nombre de
produits des produits matures il y a une
très forte hausse de la demande tout
simplement parce que on est dans la
l'accélération de la transition
démographique prenez juste la France 25
% de la pop ultion française à plus de
60 ans c'est ces 25 % là consomme plus
que tout le reste de la population ces
25 % vont devenir 33 % dans 20 ans si
vous prenez les plus de 75 ans il
consomment en moyenne 3 unités par jour
et c'est cette cette population de 75
ans va doubler dans les 20 ans qui
viennent bon donc on efface la hausse de
la consommation de médicament était de
l'ordre de 2 à 3 % jusqu'au années 2010
on est passé 3 à 4 % aujourd'hui l'année
dernière on est à + 9 % en volume ça
c'est pour la France pour
l'OPE
très fort en même temps on a eu une
réduction de la base de la production
pour les raisons qui ont été évoqué
c'est-à-dire comme le modèle économique
n'était pas assez rentable pour les Big
Pharma ils ont délocalisé et externalisé
à des sous-traitants mais avec un nombre
de fabricants qui s'est considérablement
réduit donc ça c'est une situation qui
est là et qui qui qui va nécessiter un
choc on viendra sur les solution plus
tard mais en effet c'est un phénomène
mondial pour cette raisonlà et si on ne
fait pas de choc de réindustrialisation
mais pas de la France hein c'est pas à
l'échelle de la France qu'on on y
reviendra sur la chose deuxièmement il y
a pas que la disponibilité des
médicaments qui qui qui est un problème
en France on était les les premiers
derrière les Américains il y a 20 ans en
terme d'innovation on est aujourd'hui
entre la 15e la 20e place bref on est on
a vraiment perdu beaucoup de
compétitivité on était les premiers
producteurs d'Europe il y a 15 ans on
est aujourd'hui les 5è on s'est fait
doubler par les Italiens par les Anglais
par les Suisses par les Irlandais donc
on on voit bien qu'il y a un problème de
notre politique de médicament qui n'est
pas suffisamment ambitieuse ou qui ne
fait pas du médicament et de la santé un
un un un un secteur suffisamment
stratégique on a désinvesti dans la
recherche puis on a désinvesti dans dans
dans la production on a raté le virage
des biotechnologies on est toujours
massivement avec une production de
produits chimi qui sont au fur et à
mesure d' l'évolution des technologieses
de moins en moins stratégique bref donc
on a un problème de politique numque
qu'on ne veut pas voir la le dernier
point c'est qu'il y a un entrelacement
de la crise du médicament de la pénuriie
du médicament avec la crise systémique
puis parce qu'il y a pas qu'une pénurie
de produits de santé il y a une pénurie
de soignant à l'hôpital dans dans les
épades et dans les chos donc on voit
bien qu'on a une crise de la santé qu'on
ne veut pas voir non plus donc je je
crois que tant qu'on ne voudra pas
regarder si vous voulez de façon un peu
globale et structurelle et on va venir
sur sur les problèmes il y a un problème
d'organisation de l'État si vous voulez
qui on a une super étatisation on a
ultra bureaucratisé des agences
régionales de santé qui sont des Mamou
des mammouths bureaucra vous nous faites
vraiment le tableau global non mais
parce que tout ça rentre en tout ça r
mais j'ai bien y a il y a trois choses
hein si vous voulez il y a des choses
spécifiques au médicament mais si vous
voulez bon donc juste pour reprendre sur
sur l'aspect systémique à partir du
moment où il y a pas de vision long
terme ce qu'il n'y a pas pour les
hôpitaux pour tous les acteurs de santé
c'est encore plus grave pour des
industriels parce que les industriels
pour qu'ils investissent siz il leur
faut quand même une certaine stabilité
et une vision de long terme sur sur la
politique et de santé en générale ce
qu'on ne fait pas parce qu'on a une
vision budgétaire de court terme donc
voilà donc on va parler des solution de
court terme comme avec le ministre mais
mais je pense que tant que qu'on ne
pensera pas véritablement à une refonte
et je vous dirais quelques idées làus
dans un instant laquelle exactement
Nathalie coutinet c'est vrai qu'en
préparant l'émission On connaît ce
problème de pénurie mais on se rend
compte que nos labos même si peut-être
qu'on est moins performant à l'échelle
mondiale qu'il y a quelques années n'ont
aucune usine de backup Sanofi par
exemple n'a plus aucune usine de secours
c'està-dire que la la chaîne est à flux
tendu en permanence il suffit d'un grain
de sable et on a un problème
d'approvisionnement c'est ça aujourd'hui
la situation bien sûr en fait maintenant
les les firmes pharmaceutiques depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est-à-dire à
partir de du moment où les pénuries
commencent à croître de manière
exponentielle on a effectivement des
laboratoires pharmaceutique qui sont
organisés comme n'importe quelle autre
entreprise qui sont très financiarisé
peut-être plus financiarisé que dans
d'autres secteurs puisque ce sont les
grands fonds d'investissement américains
qui détiennent ces firmes
pharmaceutiques pizer Sanofi c'est croc
qui est bien connu en France hein qui
est un des grand AC un énorme
investisseur financi des milliards et
des milliards de chiffr d'affaires et
donc l'objectif des fes pharmaceutiques
aujourd'hui de ces grands laboratoires
c'est de de satisfaire la rentabilité
des actionnaires et pour ça ils se sont
comme le disait votre collègue ils se
sont tournés vers les produits les plus
innovants parce que les prix sont très
élevés et ils ont abandonnner
progressivement les ce qu'on appelle les
médicaments matures c'estàd les
médicaments qu'on perdu le brevet
médicament matur c'est dont dont le
brevet est tombé dans le domaine donc
qui peuvent être produits par mais qui
peuvent être essentiel à la santé hein
faut dire c'est pas parce qui sont
anciens qui sont pas Essen il peuvent
être anciens mais effectivement ils
peuvent être très importants et en fait
les industriels ont pas jouer le jeu
qu'avait proposé mais c'est un peu dans
tous les pays la même chose c'estàd de
bien rémunérer l'innovation c'estàd que
les prix aujourd'hui pour les
médicaments innovants sont très élevé
mais la contrepartie c'était de baisser
le prix des médicaments anciens sur
lesquels la rentabilité avait été plus
que faite et en réaction à ça qu'est-ce
qu'on fait les laboratoires ben ils ont
soit arrêté de produire soit externalisé
et on a effectivement comme le disait
Frédéric sur certains médicaments très
peu de producteurs peut-être un dans le
monde alors là il va y avoir des petites
augmentation de prix pour obliger
justement les les estce très juste Lab
l'industrie à reproduire certains
médicament plus 10 % notamment sur la
micycline oui mais ce que disait le le
président de biogarant est très
intéressant si on ne fait que des
génériques effectivement on on n'est pas
rentable parce que la rentabilité au
moment où ces génériques avaient des
brevets c'était les Big Pharma qui les
produisait donc il y a aussi une
injustice puisque finalement en
externalisant les médicaments anciens et
bien les producteurs de ces médicaments
ont des difficultés à être rentable donc
on a toute une politique aussi parmi
effectivement les choses qu'il faut
revoir sans doute la façon de fixer les
prix des médicaments alors on va y venir
comment fixer le prix des on entend
parler aussi d'un pôle public du
médicament peut-être que l'Étap peut
reprendre la main sur tous les
médicaments qu'on arrive plus à faire
fabriquer par les industriel dans dans
notre pays mais d'abord pour se figurer
un peu les choses on va revoir un peu ce
qui se passe en image dans dans les
pharmacies c'est un reportage de
Baptiste Garg Chartier tourné dans
plusieurs pharmacies Paris Marseille
avec les équipes de France Télé
regardez comme un air de déjà vu l'hiver
derni ni certains antibiotiques
manquaient à l'appel et avaient connu
des soucis
d'approvisionnement alors la France
va-t-elle de nouveau subir une pénurie
équivalente à celle de l'an dernier à en
croire cette pharmacie située au cœur de
Paris rupture de stock d'antibiotiqu qui
traitent notamment les infections plus
d'augmenttin quasiment plus d'amoxyiline
oui alors effectivement depuis plusieurs
semaines voire plusieurs mois on a des
problèmes d'approvisionnement sur les
antibiots en général donc amoxyyine
amoxyine accideav on essaie de voir avec
des confrères si on peut être dépanné
par nos confrères sinon on appelle le
médecin pour un changement de de
prescription et à l'approche de l'hiver
les clients sont inquiets surtout ce qui
est inquiétant c'est que c'est pas la
première année on le sait qu'on a
entendu beaucoup de déclarations qu' se
passe rien oui c'est ennuyeux qu' a des
problèmes d'approvisionnement ça
n'existait pas de bon époque non c'est
pas normal on est quand même un un grand
pays donc on devrait avoir la capacité
de
de régénérer nos nos nos stocks dans le
sud de la France même constate dans
cette pharmacie marseillaise plus une
seule boîte d'antibiotiques qui traite
les infections le problème c'est qu'il
manque des médicaments qui sont majeurs
on parle d'antibiotiques d'antibiotique
pour les enfants comme cette dernière
boîte d'amoxyiline que cette
pharmacienne s'est procurée dans ce
laboratoire marseillais spécialisé dans
la fabrication de
médicaments là je vais placer les
gélules au niveau du gélulier pour
palier les ruptures de stock 50
préparateurs sont à l'œuvre et produit
sur demande les traitements manquants
dans ce laboratoire accollé à l'officine
depuis plus d'un an la production a
augmenté de 30 % on le fait d'ailleurs
pour tous nos confrères donc ça c'est un
point important c'est une quarantaine de
farmacies en France qui sont spécialisés
làdedans et qui concentent cette
activité qui ensuite distribué sur tout
le territoire cette année les autorités
de santé l'assurent les risques de
rupture de stock seront plus ou moins
cet hiver selon l'intensité des
épidémies bonsoir Jean-François Rousset
vous êtes à distance depuis l'Avon votre
circonscription vous êtes député
Renaissance merci d'être là en quelques
mots on voit quelques pistes évoqué par
le le gouvernement qui convoque toute la
filière la semaine prochaine au
ministère de de la santé pour vous les
premiers responsables de ces pénurie de
de médicaments ce sont les
industriels je pense que c'est plus
compliqué que ça euh dans l'ordre il y a
d'abord la prévention des infections et
si on sait utiliser des vaccinations
comme les vaccinations contre la grippe
la covid et la broncholite on peut se
passer d'antibiotiques s'il y a pas de
surinfection après le circuit du
médicament est très compliqué euh il y a
probablement une analyse à faire et
c'est ce que propose le ministre
Aurélien Rousseau quand il veut mettre
tous les gens autour de la table pour
mettre à la fois les industriels les
répartiteurs les grandes pharmacies les
petites pharmacies donc c'est vrai que
s'il y a un souci il il faut anticiper
ça fait plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois que qu'on connaît ce problème mais
il y a aussi prob prix c'est une
solution pour vous ou pasors puis qu'on
en est au chapitre des solutions sur le
médicament pour forcer les industriels à
produire en
FR il faudrait arriver à relocaliser la
production de médicament en France c'est
une volonté du président mais ça se fait
pas sur un claquement de doigt les
incitations par l'augmentation du prix
ça veut dire que les industriels auront
intérêt à à vendre plus de médicaments
parce qu'il les vendront plus cher mais
je pense que c'est pas la seule et
unique solution voilà je je moi je
trouve que pr alors d'un mot monsieur le
député d'abord de mieux répartir et
d'éviter les stock les stocks inutiles
euh ensuite encourager les les Français
à faire moins de stock dans leur
pharmacie propre parce que c'est si je
suis sûr que la pénurie dans les dans
les che che chez les les particuliers
n'est pas la même que celle de des
officines et je trouve que ce que vous
avez présenté qui paraît une bonne piste
c'est de permettre à des farm pharmacie
des laboratoires de d'officine souvent
adossés à des des pharmacies des
hôpitaux publics de fabriquer les
molécules essentiels les antibiotiques
et les antiouleurs les antipirétiques ça
me paraît une très bonne solution parmi
d'autres merci beaucoup monsieur le le
député Rousset benénedict Bertholom
c'est vrai que le gouvernement avec le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a permis la vente à
l'unité et c'est un petit peu pour
prolonger la réflexion de de de ce
député ça peut changer les choses ou là
c'est du cosmétique alors clairement
nous on est complètement défavorable à
cette solution oui on l'a déjà dit à
plusieurs reprises bah parce que c'est
une mauvaise réponse à une bonne
question en fait ça fait moins d'argent
aussi pour les pharmaciens peut-être
alors je pense pas que ça soit ça
puisque ça serait rémunéré mais c'est la
problématique c'est que en fait il y a
pas de sécurité quand il va y avoir une
dispensation à l'unité aujourd'hui en
fait le pharmacien va découper une boîte
il va donner un médicament dans un
sachet en vraque mais comment il va
faire s'il y a un retrait de l'eau il va
devoir aller se rappeler queil a donné
tel médicament dans tel sachet à tel
patient et cetera et en terme de
faisabilité comment ça va se passer si
c'est un sirop qui est en rupture
comment va faire le pharmacien pour
aller donner un petit peu de sirop à
chaque enfant c'est c'est c'est pas
faisable en fait même dans l'urgence en
étant on sait bien que relocaliser ça va
prendre du temps ça semble du bon sens
non Nathalie contintinet la vente à
l'unité c'est pas c'est pas quelque
chose qui au moins peut palier l'urgence
ça serait du bon sens si les industriels
conditionn de manière à ce qu'on puisse
vendre à l'unité mais comme les
conditionnements ne sont pas faits pour
vendre à l'unité
non mais dans les pays dans lesquels il
y a de la ventale unité les
conditionnements des industriels
prévoient la ventale unité effectivement
on voit pas très bien d'abord en général
quand même la plupart du temps les
boîtes correspondent peu ou pro au
traitement donc on voit pas le
pharmacien enlever deux deux Gélu de
chaque plaquette pour constituer une
autre boîte bon c'est un peu du
bricolage et en aucun cas c'est de
nature à résoudre le problème et quand
le le le député dit les gens ont des
médicaments chez eux c'est vrai même
même le ministre a dit attention
on consomme plus de médicament les
patients les malades peuvent avoir
beaucoup de médics chez eux pourquoi on
consomme plus de médicaments parce que
les gens sont de mauvaise volonté tout
d'un coup sont devenus des gros
consommateurs comme ça enfin il y a des
déterminants qui sont connus de longue
date tout ça on aurait pu l'anticiper il
y a aucune surprise au fait qu'une
population comme la France consomme
beaucoup plus de médicaments en 2023
qu'en 2013 dés de vous dire qu'est-ce
qu'on fait d'abord on doit franchement
être très très mauvais tous
universitaires ou autre parce que on a
l'impression de parler des un un mur
voyez c'estàd qu'on essaie d'expliquer
qu'il y a quelque chose de structurel et
qu'il faut regarder sous le capot et en
fait il y a aucune volonté ou tout du
moins il y a que la volonté de parier
sur la bonne volonté des acteurs et de
dire toi tu as pas été gentil parce que
tu as tuas surstocké ta machine donc on
doit pas être assez clair mais voyez on
évite le le vrai problème alors sur le
moyen long terme comment est-ce qu'on
peut
réindustrialiser les Américains l'ont
fait ils l'ont pas fait avec un pôle
public mais ils l'ont fait pas avec un
pôle lucratif avec un pô d'un secteur
non lucratif c'està-dire que la
problématique c'est de de d'attirer des
investisseurs donc pour ça il faut êre
être attractif en matière de
marché
relocaliseéresse ça n'intéresse pas ça
nintéresse pas la majorité des
investisseurs la preuve sur les 100
millions d'euros qui a coûté l'usine
dans le rô pour relocaliser le dolipran
il a fallu mettre on ne sait pas très
bien mais peut-être les 2/ers d'argent
public donc évidemment si l'État
finance c'est pas attractif le modèle
économique n'est pas attractif donc il
faut le rendre attractif comment vous
pouvez le faire ce qu'on fait les
Américains c'est que vous garantissez à
des industriels un marché sur un temps
suffisamment long 5 à 10 ans avec une
rentabilité suffisante pour qu'ils
puisse investir c'est une centaine de
millions une quel marché les les
médicaments innovants les
anciens que l'on connait donc non les
nouveau il y a pas de problème parce que
justement ils sont rentables quand vous
mais est-ce que on peut redevenir
attractif sur ce secteurl donc moi je
pense très concrètement il y a plusieurs
façons de faire mais très concrètement
je pense qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait un
consortium à l'échelle de l'Europe et je
pense que la France ferait bien d'en
prendre leg un peu ce qu'on a fait avec
Airbus si vous voulez parce que c'est
trop long la procédure à travers l'Union
européenne je pense prendrait trop de
temps avec des désaccords d'un certain
nombre de pays et je pense qu'il faut
créer ce marché-là en le rendant
attractif pour des médicaments matures
que l'on sait qui vont rester
durablement en tension ou en rupture
parce qu'on sait qui a ce déséquilibre
entre l'offre et la demande et ça on est
quand même capable de les identifier et
recréer un pôle de production à partir
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs on manque
ni d'argent ni de savoir-faire ni
d'industriel et ça ça sera compétitif
avec la Chine et l'Inde c'est possible
ben bien sûr que c'est possible à partir
du moment où vous rendez le le le le
marché attractif donc et de toute façon
on est condamné à le faire parce que
encore une fois les Américains ont très
bien compris ça puisqu'ils l'ont fait à
travers mais on relocalise aussi quand
même il faut faut le dire on commence
enfin si si on relocalise d'abord vous
voyez que une fois qu'on a relocalisé
qu'on a mis 100 millions dans dans une
usine sanofice est précipité pour ce qui
a été très bien expliqué par Nathalie
c'est-à-dire cette ultra
financiarisation qui ne fait que du
profit le guide de choix bfarma Ren
bigfarma c'est leur façon de faire enfin
on a vu quand même ave pharmaciie qui
viennent avec Sanofi qui vient de se
séparer de son pôle santé grand public
dans lequel il y a le doliprane et parce
que c'est pas assez rentable on le donne
au marché financiers en disant on va
faire une introduction en Bourse comme
c'est pas assez rentable pour nous vous
pensez vraiment que ça va être assez
rentable pour les marchés financiers si
c'est pas assez rentable pour les Big
Pharma ça peut l'être que c'est pas le
même modèle économique
mais je suis d'accord avec vous non mais
je suis d'accord natthalie coutinet
c'est vrai que il y a l'argent privé des
big pharmas comme on les appelle les
industries pharmaceutiques et puis
l'argent public parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'aide publique à la recherche et à
l'innovation dans le marché du
médicament est-ce qu'il faut
conditionner ces aides publiques on
pense au crédit d'impôt recherche est-ce
qu'il faut changer les économie d'aide
publique dans ce secteurlà alors le
problème c'est qu'on on parle en même
temps de deux sous-catégories de marché
de médic qui sont pas les mêmes en fait
il y a les médicaments innovants qui
sont effectivement dont la recherche est
largement subventionné par les États
quel que soit la manière dont c'est que
ce soit direct ou indirect mais ceux-là
n'ont pas de problème de rentabilité
puisqu'ils sont très chers donc cela
finalement on peut dire que les Big
Pharma font des profits sur l'argent
public et en plus le marché est rendu
solvable parce que les médicaments sont
remboursés donc il y a aucun problème le
problème qui se pose aujourd'hui à nous
c'est les médicaments matures c'est des
médicaments qui sont peu chers qui sont
anciens mais qui restent très efficaces
et pour lesquels le problème de demande
est encore plus important puisque les
les pays émergents ceux qui commencent
et qui dont la consommation de
médicament augmente euh consomment
justement ces médicaments matures qui
sont moins chers puisque c'est souvent
des pays en développement donc comme le
disait Frédéric le problème sur les
médicaments matures on va l'avoir
pendant des années c'est pas l'année
prochaine on peut se revoir et vous
direz il y a plus 3700 médicaments
rupture mais 4000 4500 bon je sais pas
justuse avec les perte de chance que ça
applique pour les malades et les
pouvoirs publics qui finalement ne
prennent pas la mesure du problème quand
j'entends le ministre qui dit c'est
parce que les les patients ont des
médicaments chez eux mais vous croyez
que j'ai des anticancéreux dans ma boîte
à pharmacie faut être quand même un tout
petit peu pas dire n'importe quoi au
gens non plus je suis désolée donc
effectivement il faut que pour ces
médicaments matures s'inspirer du modèle
américain dans lequel vous avez des
hôpitaux parce que comme les prix
étaient plus trop élevés sur les
génériques et que il y avait trop de
rupture ils se sont organiser pour faire
produire pour eux-mêmes en étant les
acheteurs et ça garantit comme le disit
il garantissent le marché ils
garantissent le marché et donc
aujourd'hui vous avez plus de 150
hpitaux américains qui s'approvisionnent
pour un certain nombre de marchés sur ce
producteur qui est non non profite ça ça
veut dire une guerre commerciale aussi
hein il faut le dire franchement aux
frontières s'en fich les big pharmas' F
pas produire ça l'exemple s'enè non mais
son sont des sous-traitants c'est c'est
une hautre industrie hein comme a dit
Nathalie vous avez deux Industri Barère
à Pharma qui qui part de la Red et qui
produit qui ne produit pas les produits
innovants et puis vous avez l'industrie
des produits matures qui sont des
industriels pur et dur qui savent
parfaitement produire à Bakou des
grandes quantités c'est c'est avec eux
qu'il faut travailler sur il y a pas de
recherche sur ces médicaments là donc
ils sont c'est pas le même modèle
économique leordsi qu'est-ce que ça ça
vous inspire parce que on on se rend
compte c'est carrément non bien sûr mais
c'est un Big Bang qui prendra énormément
de temps c'est vrai qu'on se demande
pourquoi il y a pas une sorte de service
public du médicament vous vous l'avez
déjà évoqué moi ça m' fait penser aussi
lorsqu'il y avait le le covid où la
stratégie vaccinale avait été confié à
des organismes privés comme mckinse
parce que il y avait un manque d'agent
public pour pouvoir gérer ça et on a
l'impression que derrière tout ça il y a
quand même voilà on a on a pas
suffisamment mis en place place des
services publics pour pour fa ça et
peut-être que l'argent aussi qui a qui a
été donné à minse bon c'est un petit peu
à enfin un pas de côté par rapport à
notre débat mais aurait pu servir
peut-être enfin j'ai lu ça en tout cas
dans une tribune qui était qui é très
intéressante aurait pu servir pour pour
relocaliser euh c'est vrai qu'après les
pandémies on s'est senti tous
extrêmement démunis et que ça a sauté
aux yeux les pharmaciens qu'est-ce
qu'ils attendent parce que on parle d'un
pôle public du médicament est-ce que ça
c'est une une demande qui pourrait euh
aider les pharmaciens à garantir euh les
les stocks ce qui pourrait aider les
pharmaciens c'est euh et la population
surtout c'est renforcer la transparence
aujourd'hui ce qu'on attend c'est de
savoir euh où sont les médicaments et
aujourd'hui en fait on est dans un ce
qu'a appelé le gouvernement un triangle
des Bermudes on ne sait pas où sont les
médicaments et en fait si on ne sait pas
où sont les médicaments on ne peut pas
agir en fait on ne peut pas euh prévenir
et anticiper ces ruptur c'est-à-dire que
vous voudriez avoir moyen de fécher les
stocks est-ce qu'ils sont dans les
usines des industrielles ou ils sont été
exportés par
rétiteur et aujourdhui il y a un
qui s'appelle le DP rupture qui existe
depuis 10 ans que le ministre a cité
récemment et ce DP rupture doit être
obligatoire pour l'ensemble de la chaîne
de distribution des médicaments que ce
soit les laboratoires les grossistes
répartiteurs les les officinaux et les
Hospitaliers si nous savons où sont les
ruptures les médicaments les stocks à ce
moment-là nous pourrons agir et l'État
la NSM pourra agir d'accord avec ça oui
mon d'ailleurs le rapport de de du Sénat
qui a un excellent rapport sur cette
question a bien montré qu'on était
incapable de remonter la chaîne de
production d'un médicament personne
n'est capable de dire ce médicament qui
est dans telle officine exactement qui
l'a produit quelles ont été les étapes
donc il y a un vrai problème de
transparence à la fois sur toute la
chaîne de production et aussi sur toute
la chaîne de financement des médicaments
donc c'est vrai que c'est un triangle
des Bermudes c'est une belle une belle
expression un point làdessus pour
terminer pour conoui le point le point
commun de de la crise systémique dont je
parlais c'est que par exemple et ça
vient d'être évoquer proposé par
l'Institut santé donc je peux le redire
c'est c'est de créer un service public
territorial de santé c'estàdire de
généraliser les valeurs fondamentales du
service public qui sont la continuité du
service l'égalité d'accès et la
mutabilité c'est de l'adaptation au
technologie des chos donc il faut
intégrer en fait même si ce sont des
acteurs privés à but lucratif il faut
les intégrer dans une régulation de
service public à l'échelle de l'ensemble
du portefeuille de Chac la deuxième
chose c'est qu'il faut partir des
besoins faut pas partir de l'offre ce
qui a été très bien dit c'est qu'en fait
on a une régulation qui est à l'aveugle
on ne connaît même pas nos besoins parce
que on ne les suit pas on est tout à
fait capable de savoir ce que l'on va
consommer en 2024 par rapport en 2023
mais c'est ça qui doit être le guide de
la régulation or on demande au
laboratoire d'être leur propre guide en
disant ayez 2 mois de stock mais c'est
pas au laboratoire d'avoir la vision
nationale qui répondre au besoins c'est
l'État qui doiv piloter une stratégie
d'ensemble merci beaucoup c'était
important d'avoir ce débat il est pas
simple il va pas se régler forcément à
qu'el échelle nationale on l'a bien
compris et et merci de de de vos
éclairages on s'arrête là vous restez
avec moi Lorde aussi dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir vous allez découvrir
maître Bertrand Perrier dans une pldoir
et en faveur de l'écriture inclusive
tempête c'est le mot de la semaine de
Mariette dargrand et puis de quoi nous
parlez-vous dans Action planète les app
Falco bah cette semaine on se demande
comment un donut peut nous aider à
comprendre la transition écologique ah
hâte de vous entendre mais d'abord on va
plonger dans la réputation aux éditions
Les échappé lors d'ussi votre livre
raconte ces jeunes fille de la cité de
Cray dans looise la ville où a été
poignardée et brûlé vif China 15 ans
vous vous êtes retourné là-bas 4 ans
après cette affaire terrifiante un
véritable fait de société pour essayer
de comprendre comment elles vivent
aujourd'hui ces jeunes filles et comment
les garçons veulent les transformer en
filles dites facile regardez
l'invitation est signée ce soir par
Stéphanie Despierre et on en parle
toutes les deux juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite lors d'si c'est
pour parler de cette mauvaise réputation
celle qui colle à la peau des filles
dans certains quartiers et qui peut-être
mortel journaliste à Charlie hebbdo dans
votre livre vous racontez l'histoire de
Shain une pétillante jeune fille de 15
ans poignardée puis brûlé vive par son
petit ami car elle était enceinte
c'était en 2019 dans une cité de crille
son corps est retrouvé dans un cabanon
de jardin c'est inadmissible qu'on
puisse faire ça une jeune filme on est
dans un pays on doit se sentir libre et
protégé 2 ans avant sa mort Shina avait
porté plainte pour un viol collectif
depuis elle était catégorisée fille
facile c'est ce qui a attiré son petit
ami et futur meurtrier lors d'ussi vous
n'allez pas sur le terrain judiciaire
vous enquêtez sur la fabrique des filles
faciles vous décrivez le terrible
contrôle social et religieux qui
s'exerce sur les jeunes filles du
quartier du Plateau rouer où vivait SH
ses amis vous racontent comment les
garçons impose leurs interdits c'est
super triste à dire mais c'est la même
ambiance que si on vivait en Algérie on
ne doit pas trop montrer notre corps pas
s'habiller trop court pour vous c'est
une brigade des meœurs qui ne dit pas
son nom et puis il y a cette phrase
effroyable d'un père de famille je
préfère avoir mon fils en prison qu'une
fille qui soit une traînée votre livre
est glaçon mais nécessaire à votre
grande surprise ces adolescentes n'ont
jamais entendu parler de Mitou le phénom
d'ailleurs semble les avoir oublié en
2002 déjà une jeune fille Soan mourait
brûlé vive à Vitri sur scène sur fond de
vengeance entrebande son meurtre avait
bouleversé la France et provoqué la
création du mouvement féministe ni
ni soumise c'était il y a 20 ans et on a
l'impression que rien n'a changé alors
nous avons une question l d'ussi où sont
les féministes dans ce combat pour la
liberté des filles dans les quartiers
réponse leur dossier c'est une question
qu'on me pose souvent en réalité ell
elles sont là tout de même pas toutes
mais une grande partie des féministes
sont là elles sont pour beaucoup sur le
terrain il y a des FAM familiales des
associations de quartiers pour
accompagner oui il y a il y a je conacre
un chapitre aux associations il y a un
certain nombre de de difficultés pour
beaucoup d'entre elles parce que manque
de moyens parce que aussi certaines
associations sont influencées par une
forme de de communautarisme où certaines
militantes sont pas forcément bien
formées et donc vont reproduire certains
stéréotypes il y a un malaise chez
certaines d'entre elles des féministes à
dénoncé le sexisme qu y a chos parce
qu'il y a il y a celles qui sont dans le
quartier qui essayent de faire des
choses et d'ailleurs dans d'autres
quartiers aussi au quotidien dont on
entend jamais parler ou pas assez euh il
y a peut-être dans les discours pour le
coup médiatiqu euh peut-être une une
gêne de la part de certaines féministes
que que je que je déplore peut-être une
volonté de ne pas
stigmatiser de de ne pas pointer en
particulier certains quartiers moi à
l'inverse je dis que le plus
stigmatisant ce serait d'abandonner ces
adolescentes à leur situation et je
rappelle tout au long de mon livre que
les violences faites aux femmes sont
partout dans tous les territoires dans
tous les milieux je pense que c'est
important aussi de l'avoir en tête mais
je ne m'interdis pas de pointer en
particulier le sexisme que je dis
exacerbé extrêmement violent que vivent
ces adolescentes avec ce contrôle au
quotidien cette surveillance au
quotidien qui n'est pas forcément le le
lot de de de tout le monde alors
vous-même vous avez d'abord fui le sujet
trop sordide écrivez-vous trop révoltant
alors qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé
finalement à enquêter sur cette affaire
Shina et à enquêter d'une certaine
manière sur toute une ville oui c'est
vrai que je je j'ai d'abord eu ce
mouvement un peu de recul parce que
c'est un féminicide comme tous les
féminicides HE mais qui est est
particulièrement atroce mais ensuite je
me suis dit il faut il faut s'en emparer
il faut comprendre comment on en est
arrivé là et j'ai d'abord travaillé sur
ce sujet pour charliedo et en allant à
crille j'ai là commencé à recueillir la
parole de certaines adolescentes qui me
disaient avoir peur de vivre le même
sort que Shina qu' elle me racontait
donc ce contrôle constant quotidien de
la part de certains petits groupes de
garçons et je me suis dit il y a là un
sujet important et donc c'est comme ça
que je me suis dit qu'il fallait en
faire un livre euh et euh alors rambau
Binon Shina brune en jouet au longs
cheveux bruns a été victime à 13 ans
d'un viol collectif qui lui a
cruellementvu la réputation de fille
impure mais elle n'a pas abdiqué elle a
pororté plainte puis 2 ans plus tard en
2019 elle a été poingardée et brûlée
vive par son ex peti ami parce que elle
serait tombée enceinte et que la
publicité de cette relation menaçait
d'entacher son honneur à lui vous avez
suivi pour Charlie Hebdo le procès vous
racontez une partie de ce procès dans
dans votre livre qui frappe c'est cette
constante mauvaise réputation qui ne
cesse d'une certaine manière de désigner
Shain à la vindicte et de l'exposer au
danger oui c'est vrai que ce cette
notion de réputation est extrêmement
présente c'est une épée de damoclesès
au-dessus de la tête de toutes les
filles que j'ai rencontré et et en effet
c'est un peu cette notion qui est est en
partie euh responsable du du meurtre de
Shain parce que euh cette histoire est
terrifiante dès le début donc vous
l'avez dit il a été agressé sexuellement
à l'âge de 13 ans par des garçons euh
qui ensuite ont propagé dans toute la
cité l'anathème éminemment sexiste de
fille facilees auquel je mets évidemment
des des guillemets euh et donc et qui va
et qui va survivre à sa mort c'est ça
qui est incroyable et terrifiant cette
réputation de fille facile va va lui
survivre il va y avoir d'ailleurs peu de
personnes qui participent à la marche
blanche euh vous avez rencontré des
jeunes hommes à à Cray qui continue à
remettre en cause sa parole à minimiser
nbre garçons collec voilà ils condamnent
tous le meurtre fort heureusement mais
en effet
quelquesuns disent oui cette agression
sexuelle on n'est pas tout à fait sûr
elle avait une réputation c'est souvent
le le mot qui revient comme ça euh et
donc il mit minimise sa sa sa parole
voilà et c'est vrai que Shain finalement
sa parole a été remise en cause de
nombreux aspects à la fois par les
habitants les garçons et aussi je
développe par par par la justice et par
différents acteurs judiciair pluss
institutions judicièrees et policières
voilà absolument et c'est vrai que c'est
assez euh euh effrayant de voir à quel
point euh il y a un certain nombre de
failles ou dès dès qu'elle vient en
auprès de la police pour témoigner la la
policière écrit mentionnons nous
mentionnons que Shina ne ne présente
aucune émotion particulière ce qui est
certainement certainement le phénomène
de sidération euh qu'on peut ressentir
après une agression sexuelle et c'est
assez surprenant que la policière écrive
ça noir sur blanc comme si ça ça ça
sous-entendait que Shina n'avait rien
vécu il y a aussi le médecin une femme
médecin qui osculte Shina le soir même
de l'agression et qui dit Shina se
déshabille facilement et ne semble
prouver aucun affect de honte ni de
culpabilité comme si elle devait en
éprouver ou c'est toute la société
finalement qui ne veut pas l'entendre
comment comment vous avez fait pour
rencontrer ces jeunes filles à Cray en y
retournant pour pour qu'elle vous parle
sans difficulté de ce de ce contrôle
sexiste m misogy qu'ell subissent alors
je j'en ai rencontré un certain nombre
lors d'une d'une cérémonie d'hommage à
China don j'avais pris leurs contact je
les ai recontacté par la suite et
finalement les avait plutôt envie de me
parler c'est ça aussi qui me donne un
peu d'espoir c'est que finalement elles
avaient envie elles ont envie que ça ça
change et et j'espère que ça pourra être
le cas en leur donnant la parole elles
avaient envie de dénoncer ce qu'elle ce
qu'elles subissent bon beaucoup
malheureusement leur seul échappatoire
c'est de partir de crille mais certaines
sont obligés encore de rester ou
certaines me disent ma petite sœur est
encore là elle subit encore ça quand
elles vous disent si tu montres tes
formes on va dire que tu l' chercher qui
est ce on qui sont eux parce que il on
entend tout le temps ne sont jamais
véritablement nommé de qui parle-t-on
est-ce que c'est l'islam régoriste qui
qui pèse dans ces quartiers est-ce que
ce sont les les grands frère de qui
parle-t-on c'est un peu multifactoriel
et en effet j'intitule un chapitre e
parce que j'avais l'impression tous les
films me parlaient d'une comme de ces
garçons comme d'une masse informe un peu
indéfinie qui pesait au-dessus d'elle en
les réalité c'est un petit c'est une
minorité de de garçons mais dont
l'influence est assez importante hein et
il y a d'autres garçons qui dénonc ces
attitudesl qui veulent aussi que ça
évolue donc c'est pas tous les garçons a
dans le même sac voilà c'est important
je le soulligne et vous l'avez dit oui
il y a c'est multifactoriel il y a en
partie l'intégrisme religieux qui joue
un rôle je raconte que je vais à la
rencontre de l'imam un d'un des imames
de crille à qui je rapporte certains
témoignages d'adolescents dont une à qui
on a dit dans la rue qu'elle ne devait
pas habillé en jupe et il me dit je vous
confirme que la jupe est est un interdit
religieux alors c'est son point de vue
son interprétation bien d'autres imams
disent tout à fait autre chose mais on
peut supposer que s'il répercute ça dans
ses prêches et bien certains garçons se
sont autorisé ensuite à surveiller à
contrôler les adolescentes le le tabou
absolu c'est qu' il faut rester vierge
au mariage ça elles le disent ou
absolument elles me le disent pas tout
de suite quand on est dans une une
relation de confiance elle me dit c'est
vraiment ça qui est attendu et et je
pense que ça c'est assez méconnu mais
c'est une des spécificités je pense un
des terreos le plus important qui qui
crée ensuite ce sexisme et ce risque de
réputation et une mère de famille me
disait je sais très bien que ici quand
un garçon touche une fille s'en est
terminé pour elle tous les autres
garçons pensent qu'elle va être d'accord
elle tombe immédiatement dans cette
catégorie de fille facile voilà donc
c'était cette injonction dont il faut
avoir conscience et je pense aussi dont
euh les féministes devraient davantage
avoir conscience pour déconstruire ces
stéréotypes et ces injonctions comment
expliquez-vous qu'elle n'ait pas entendu
parler de la vague Mitou elles sont
connectées ces jeunes filles elles sont
sur les réseaux sociaux comment est-ce
possible que cette libération de la
parole là euh ne soit pas allée jusqu'à
elle je ne me l'explique pas trop non
plus mais je le constate et et je l'ai
découvert avec grande surprise en effet
quand j'ai parlé à certaines de ces
adolescentes elles ne certaines ne
connaissaient pas meou ça correspond
d'ailleurs à 14 % de la population c'est
une étude du ha conseil à l'égalité donc
c'est quand même une certaine certain
nombre de nombre de personnes ça dit
aussi quelque chose je pense d'une
fracture dans notre société où on a
l'impression en tant que journaliste ou
voilà dans les peut-être beaucoup de
politiques ont l'impression que que tout
le monde a entendu parler du mouvement
Mitou en réalité ce n'est pas le cas
donc ça doit tous nous toutes nous
interpeller euh et c'est vrai que malgré
euh voilà le fait que ce soit ces filles
sont connectées mais il y a aussi les
algorithmes qui fait qu'on reste dans
des bulles il y a aussi un manque
d'information uneussi me dit que s'il y
avait un un un local ouvertement
féministe euh à crille et pourrait être
brûlé c'est peut-être pas le cas mais en
tout cas elle pense que ce serait le cas
donc ça dit aussi beaucoup de de de la
peur et et de l'impossibilité de se dire
féministe dans dans ce quartier euh
voilà donc c'est une fr vous croyez euh
à à une forme de comment dire De Mitou
des des quartiers comment comment le
comment le rendre possible comment
l'accompagner vous évoquez pour terminer
peut-être l'école l'éducation affective
et sexuelle quelles sont les pistes pour
rendre ces ces jeunes filles plus
confiantes dans leur avenir et surtout
les les laisser libres leur garantir
cette liberté déjà oui j'espère une
sorte de Mitou des quartiers parce que
le le mouvement Mitou c'est le fait de
prendre la parole d'être écouté et donc
c'est que font ces adolescentes en me
confiant leurs témoignag finalement donc
j'espère qu'elles seront écouté et oui
j'évoque parmi les les pistes qui
peuvent sembler mais qui sont surtout en
amont c'est l'éducation affective et
sexuelle dans les établissements
scolaires qui est une loi de 2001 très
mal appliquée et j'ai pu assister à une
de ces séances qui est absolument à la
fois glaçante et passionnante ça m'a
montré combien c'était important à la
fois
pour contrer des ignorances et des tabou
absolus autour du consentement autour de
la sexualité
et et aussi pour une libération de la
parole il y avait des petits groupes de
filles qui qui ont passé la séance
entière à raconter les les violences
qu'elles avait subi donc c'est
nécessaire de mettre en place en tout
cas ce ce livre il contribue à cette
libération de la parole lordord aussi la
réputation enquête sur la fabrique des
filles faciles entre guillemets c'est
àdire aux éditions Les échappé vous
restez avec moi c'est l'heure des
affranchis leur parties prix vont vous
faire réagir on les accueille tout de
suite bienvenue les affranchis du
vendredi maître Bertrand Perrier
Mariette d'grand notre sémiologue du
vendredi installez-vous on va commencer
comme chaque vendredi avec Léa Falco
action planè bonsoir Léa la chronique
écolo du vendredi vous nous la racontez
autour d'une notion qu'on répète sans
cesse dans les médias la transition
écologique la fameuse et c'est sans
vouloir voler évidemment le travail de
Mariette mais cette notion là elle
interroge malgré tout parce que depuis
qu'elle est rentrée dans le champ
médiatique dans le champ politique dans
champ partisan on en entend beaucoup
parler mais sous un unique prisme qui
est celui du climat quand on réfléchit à
ce qu'on associe immédiatement
instinctivement comme mot à la
transition écologique on pense éolienne
on pense centrale nucléaire on pense
plus rarement sobriété ou décarbonation
bref c'est une transition écologique qui
en fait ressemble un peu à une
transition simplement énergétique et
même s'il faut absolument parler de
climat il faut pouvoir se détacher un
petit peu de cet angeu là pour regarder
une photo qui est en fait bien plus
grande que celle du Simp le climat donc
ça va au-delà il faudrait arrêter de
parler de climat quand on parle
transition il faut absolument évidemment
continuer à parler de climat mais
surtout continuer à décarboner parce que
ça fait partie évidemment de la
transition écologique mais elle ne s'y
arrête pas et pour comprendre un peu
mieux comment on pourrait envisager
quelle grille de lecture on pourrait
adopter pour ce que moi j'appelle la
transformation écologique pour bien
montrer que c'est pas une simple
continuité que c'est une rupture avec
nos modes de vie et ben on pourra
utiliser un donut un donut parce que
c'est un modèle qui a été utilisé par
des chercheurs euh qu'on peut voir à
l'écran avec au-dessus ce qu'on appelle
des limites planétaires c'est-à-dire des
limites que l'humanité ne devrait pas
franchir au au risque de dérégler le
système terre donc on a le climat
évidemment mais il y a toutes les
questions de biodiversité les questions
lié au sol à la fertilité des sols les
questions liées au cycle de l'eau douce
et donc tout un tas de choses auxquelles
il faut faire attention d'autant plus
que c'est des enjeux qui se répondent
les uns les autres que par exemple le
changement climatique entraîne une perte
de biodiversité que la perte de
diversité va affecter la manière dont on
fait l'agriculture et cetera et cetera
et en plus ce donut là il a évidemment
au milieu un trou à l'intérieur de ce
donut là il y a le modèle d'une
économiste britannique qui s'appelle
Kate ROSO qui s'appelle le modèle du
donut en dessous on a donc cette espèce
de socle de capacités humaine
c'est-à-dire ce dont on veut que les
humains puissent bénéficier dans un
monde en transformation écologique donc
évidemment il y a la santé il y a une
alimentation il y a évidemment l'eau qui
va être un vrai enjeu en parti
particulier en France et donc ce modèle
là du donut il nous permet de voir
quelque chose qui est bien plus grand
que la simple transition énergétique
dont on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui et
effectivement c'est un modèle plus
complexe donc qui rend plus difficiles
les défis auxquels on a à faire face
mais il faut absolument avoir en tête
toute la complexité de ces modèles là
pour pouvoir avoir des réponses
adéquates formidable Bart Simpson va
adorer votre chroniquec don é donut qui
nous attendent en loge absolument non
mais si on peut y arriver avec le donut
si ça peut inciter les gens à être plus
écolo c'est for absolument il faudra
qu'on le regarde de plus près faudra
revenir Léa pour nous montrer dans le
détail ce ce donut écologique on
enchaîne avec vous Bertrand vouz revenir
sur l'inauguration par le Président de
la République de la Cité internationale
de la langue française au château de
villercôteray dans l'INE oui c'était
lundi dernier et le président de la
République a inauguré dans le château
restauré de Viller Cotret cette cité
internationale la langue française c'est
une quinzaine de salles c'est vraiment
très beau il y a un parcours à la fois
ludique et historique qui permet
d'appréhender la vitalité de la langue
française dont le point d'Or est une
sorte de verrière lexicale où pendent
des mots de la langue française mais des
mots très divers et des mots du de
langue aussi un peu canadienne ou
africaine à 10 m du sol c'est c'est
assez beau évidemment ça a duré 3 ans de
chantier ça a coûté plus de 200 millions
d'euros de travaux mais le résultat est
assez réussi évidemment le choix de
villercotteret s'impose puisque c'est
dans ce château que en 1589 François
1ier a signé sa fameuse ordonnance de
villaire cotteray qui prescrivait
l'emploi du français substitué au latin
dans les actes notamment juridiques pour
que simplement les justiciables puissent
comprendre les décisions de justice
alors on a compris que cette
inauguration vous avait beaucoup plu
peut-être la phrase présidentielle qui a
été beaucoup commenté un peu moins à
cette occasion Emmanuel Macron a évoqué
l'écriture inclusive en disant que la
langue française je cite le masculin
fait le nôtre on n'a pas besoin d'y
ajouter des points au milieu des mots
oui al c'est une façon assez étonnante
d'aborder le débat sur l'écriture
inclusive que je trouve à la fois biaisé
et caricatural parce que d'abord on a
l'impression que pour le président de la
République le débat sur l'écriture
inclusive se cristallise et se résume à
un débat sur le point médian or le point
médian est une des formes des l'écriture
inclusive il y a a tant d'autres et tant
d'autres d'ailleurs utilisé par le
président lui-même la féminisation des
titres préf greffière ce qu'on appelle
le langage épicène c'està-dire les mots
neutres le peuple français et tant
d'autres et par exemple la double
flexion c'est-à-dire quand on dit
française français citoyenne citoyen et
même sur cette question du point médian
je voudrais dire quelque chose que ça
hystérise beaucoup les gens mais le
point médian n'est pas destiné à être lu
c'est une abréviation quand on nous dit
le point M
défigure la langue mais il ne le
défigure pas différemment que quand on
dit à la place de Monsieur M point ou
madame Mme c'est une abréviation
personne ne dirait M point Macron
personne ne dirait Mme borne et donc de
la même façon que quand on dit
citoyen.ne.s ça n'a pas vocation à être
lu ainsi et je trouve que en
cristallisant le débat sur le point
médian qui est le plus jurtiquant et
bien le président de la République
escamote le débat sur l'écriture
inclusive dans sa globalité et c'est
dommage et ce débat d'ailleurs sur
l'écriture inclusive a rebondi au Sénat
oui alors télescopage du calendrier le
jour même il y avait à l'ordre du jour
du Sénat une proposition de loi de
sénateur LR qui visait à interdire
l'emploi de l'écriture inclusive dans
des actes privés il y avait déjà eu une
circulaire d'Édouard Philippe pour
l'interdire dans les actes publiés au
Journal officiel mais là un contrat de
travail une notice ne ne pourrait pas
sous peine de nullité vous imaginez la
nullité du contrat de travail s'il était
écrit en écriture inclusive il faudra
encore que ça passe à l'Assemblée
nationale il faudrait que ça passe le
Conseil constitutionnel tout ça me
paraît assez évanescant parce que je
vois pas pourquoi une entreprise ne
pourrait pas si elle le souhaite
utiliser l'écriture inclusive en somme
ce que je veux dire pour peut-être
dédramatiser les choses c'est que
personne n'est obligé d'utiliser
l'écriture inclusive c'est toujours une
faculté c'est un choix et donc personne
ne se verra imposer ce langage s'il ne
le veut pas c'est un usage que l'on
choisit c'est un choix politique et que
d'abord ce qui doit être inclusif ça
n'est pas la langue c'est la société
pour le bien de tous et de toutes merci
Maître convaincu par la plédoirie
j'étais déjà convaincu je suis ravie
d'entendre votre pldoirie parce qu'il y
a souvent des cris d'orfris de péril
mortel et cetera autour de de l'écriture
inclusive et souvent parce qu'on ne la
connaît pas et vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire et moi j'essaie par
exemple dans mes articles d'utiliser
l'écriture inclusive sans qu'on s'en
aperçoive c'est pas forcément avec des
points des tirés effectivement je dis
par les infirmiers les infirmières parce
que ça me semble violent entre
guillemets de dire les infirmiers qui
engloberaient aussi les infirmières
qu'en plus elles sont à peu près à 90 %
ce sont des femmes voilà donc il y a
plein de président l'utilise bonsoir à
toutes et toutes en perman comme
Monsieur Jourdain en réalité mais dès
qu'on en vient au symbole du point
médian là il réduit je trouve le débat
de façon regrettableon et ben on verra
ce qu'on pense ce qui nous regarde on
aimerait bien vous interroger là-dessus
je suis sûr que vous avez une idée mais
vous aurez pas forcément le temps alors
on on fait d'abord la chronique si on
peut on entendra Mariette sur l'écriture
inclusive vous vouliez parler d'un mot
le mot de la semaine que vous avez
choisi Mariette c'est le mot tempête oui
bah le mot s'imposer pour des raisons
climatique mais c'est intéressant de
voir dans quelle mesure il est aussi par
analogie très politique ce mot alors il
est simple à comprendre Bertrand bien
sûr nos mots remontent beaucoup au au
latin c'est notre source donc le le
thème pousse la chose c'est que nous en
français le temps c'est pas comme en
anglais où on a time et weather où on
fait la différence entre la météo et
l'horloge nous c'est le se un seul mot
donc tempête a voulu dire au départ
aussi bien un moment que un phénomène
climatique c'est tout à fait intéressant
et elle n'était pas forcément cette
tempête dangereuse elle était elle
pouvait on pouvait dire je pars en
tempête calme par exemple quand une me
traversais voilà non elle est dangereuse
en fait dans les dans les écrits que
quand elle devient très sonore une
tempête c'est d'abord un vacarme un
tumulte c'est ça les synonymes tempête
et on s'en est bien aperçu dans la nuit
de de mercredi et jeudi aujourd'hui on a
plutôt le le sens figuré hein on parle
souvent de tempête médiatique ou
politique exactement mais ce sens là qui
va très vite du climatique au politique
on l'a dès le Moyen-âge he par exemple
on pouvait dire mettre tel Seigneur dans
la tourmente ou dans la tempête c'était
déjà là parce qu'en fait il y a en
substrat en dessous une image très très
forte de notre vision du politique en
Occident qui est la cité en voyage dans
des conditions plus ou moins difficiles
entre Caribes et Silas et c'est ça
gouverner ça vient du mot gouvernail
quand même il faut pas l'oublier donc
cette grande image nautique tous nos
politiques à un moment donné ou un autre
l'emploi alors j'ai regardé Charles de
Gaulle son appel du 18 juin il n'y fait
pas référence il n'a pas besoin parce
qu'il est un chef militaire mais en
juillet 45 lorsque justement il est en
train de devenir un chef politique il
réfère à cette tempête et il emploie
déjà le mot transition c'est incroyable
en 45 il dit il faut qu'on fasse la
transition parce que la tempête
c'est-à-dire la guerre et Vichi ont mis
à mal nos institution il a déjà cette
métaphore donc cette cette figure du du
président Sauveur capitaine à la barre
d'un navire en pleine tempête est un peu
grandiloquante non oui elle est très
théatrale très grandiloquante il est pas
sûr qu'elle fonctionne elle a pas marché
pour Nicolas Sarkozy en 2017 alors on
peut s'en moquer justement au théâtre
Shakespeare the Tempest il le dit en
français il le dit en roman alors qu'en
anglais le mot c'est Storm et ça c'est
pour la guerre vous vous souvenez parce
que c'est revenu dans le débat C semaine
la la campagne militaire en Irak en 91
des américains c'est la tempête du
désert c'est Desert Storm et ça c'est
beaucoup plus violent c'est ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui avec ces tempêtees
guerrière voilà alors je reviens au
thème de mon
camarade il me semble que cette écriture
inclusive effectivement elle produit
c'est une chose que nous adorons en
France et je dirais c'est la tempête
dans un verre
d'eau le c'est quand même pas
extrêmement grave mais on est capable et
la phrase du président a déclenché non
pas une polémique cette semaine
justement parce que nous sommes vraiment
entourés de vraie tempête mais quelque
chose quand même bon on aime bien un
petit peu s'enueuler autour de ce genre
de de truc mais ce qui m'intéresse
là-dedans c'est l'expression tempête
dans un verre d'eau parce que elle
semble moderne en fait elle semble un
peu argotique mais en réalité il semble
qu'elle est été créée par Sion alors je
vous la donne en latin cher Maître FL
c'estàdire flot qui déborde mais dans un
tout petit vase et donc si c'eston
l'employé pour dire écoutez il y a les
grandes tempêtes qui mettent à mal le
monde et puis il y a les petites
tempêtes qui nous amuse qui nous occupe
par vitesse de croisière merci quel
talent Mariette merci beaucoup c'est pas
mal d'avoir des petites tempêtes hein
pour l'instant on est préservé on en a
une c'est vrai météo mais d'ailleurs
dans le monde elles sont elles sont très
fortes aussi merci les affranchis merci
pour vos parties prix merci la Falco
lisez la réputation aux éditions Les les
échappé premier livre il y en aura sans
doute d'autres de leur Dossi c'est le
weekend profitez bien merci aussi à
toutes les équipes de Ça vous regarde
derrière la caméra qui m'accompagne
fidèlement dans cette émission à très
vite à la semaine prochaine très belle
soirée sur
[Musique]
LCP